when you wake up what is the first thing
you go check is there a data point is
there a platform do you go to twitter
like what do you do first thing in the
morning when you wake up and you're like
i gotta figure out what the hell is
going on
uh admittedly it's not the best habit i
probably open my phone and scroll
twitter for a bit but i've i've been
trying to get a better morning routine
going but yeah probably twitter check uh
check some macro data uh i usually wake
up before the market's open but uh yeah
just check futures uh that's that's my
life nowadays i uh uh i think a lot of
people like to uh maybe virtue signal
that uh they keep their phone in a
different room they don't check it when
they wake up every person i know they
check it when they wake up and it's
probably not healthy as you mentioned
but uh it is interesting that you go to
twitter first before you go look at any
other data points is there a data point
that you look at once you start looking
at data outside of twitter like that
you're like this is the thing i think is
most important right now to give me a
sense of what's happening
yeah i mean i'm checking the futures
markets obviously bitcoin trade 24 7. um
i mean in particular watching watching
currency markets uh nowadays and rates
um what's happening i think you talked
about it a little bit earlier in the
show
with the euro with the dollar strength
against really every major currency in a
lot of our emerging markets it's
it's quite amazing to watch um so that's
that's what i'm watching a lot nowadays
in regards to the macro um and you know
obviously the bitcoin market's chugging
along 24 7 365 so no shortage of uh of
you know kind of volatility and you know
fun market moves there
absolutely we got a couple of charts
that you uh that you want to talk
through the first is the bitcoin uh
supply that is in profit the percent of
bitcoin supply and profit uh it's a
seven day moving average uh it's down um
shocking uh what is this showing us
yeah so today's show i thought i would
you know we've talked a ton about macro
in recent months um we've also talked a
little bit about unchained on
derivatives about the counterparty risk
and the contagion i think we're just
going to strip a lot of the narrative
back a lot of like you know the macro
environment back and just looking at
previous bitcoin cycles
um i think it's because it's so much
fascinating that you know there is this
big narrative the price action is ugly
um there's certainly been a whole lot of
force selling and forced liquidations
but if we just go back and look at
previous bitcoin cycles obviously this
this current crypto bitcoin cycle
uh was an order of magnitude or you know
a lot larger than than the previous
cycles
but in relative terms it's actually not
really anything new in terms of what
we've seen previously so today's today's
kind of show is going to be focused
around some of the on-chain data and
just looking at you know
what if this bitcoin cycle this bear
cycle is pre you know compares to that
of of previous ones uh which obviously a
limited sample size only about three or
four in bitcoin's history um you know
what can we derive from that and what
may the future hold obviously uh you
know past uh you know kind of what
happened in the past doesn't translate
directly to future outcomes but it can
you know it can give us a guide to
what's happening so you know current
supply and profit uh nearing that 50
level right uh we're starting to see you
know the vast majority actually the
average uh bitcoin holder is underwater
so we're going to cover realized price
in a second but that realized price is
essentially the average cost basis of
every coin on chain that's like 22 000
today so a 20 000 bitcoin at 19 000
bitcoin your average holder is
underwater and we've seen that in
basically capitulation periods or or the
depths of bear markets and so this is
just kind of one of those gauges i mean
you could have no idea what's happening
in the macro environment and say hey you
know this is pretty this is a pretty
typical boom bust cycle for bitcoin so
it's kind of fascinating to see it all
play out in a macro downturn
and so when we start to look at those
past cycles uh on this specifically
obviously we're close to that green area
we are not in it yet uh in the past we
have gone into it is your expectation
that we have to revisit uh kind of the
depths of those drawdowns or do you
think that you know this time could be
different and we may get close but not
actually have to get that level of uh
kind of sell down on on this metric
yeah i don't necessarily think technical
analysis on a lot of these indicators is
like you know the most important factor
it's just really just kind of
contextualizing that hey
bitcoins down 70 or whatever it is from
the all-time highs
no it's not going to die yes there are a
lot of coins and a lot of and a lot of
purchases that are underwater no this is
not uh you know atypical from what we've
seen in previous boom bus cycles and
this kind of this kind of steady bleed
well i mean a lot of it was for selling
but i kind of believe that we're going
to see uh more consolidation maybe even
further further downside and more pain
in the market but it's completely
natural it's a purge from weak to strong
from inpatient to convicted and this is
what kind of sows the seeds for the next
full run this is exactly what we did in
2020 or the you know the years post 2017
bull market uh and you know bitcoin died
at three thousand dollars and people
forgot about it and you know kind of
kicked it out and what happened next
right it rallied and it didn't die
somewhat surprisingly to all the
skeptics so we're in kind of the we're
kind of in the later stages of this of
this kind of cleansing uh i wouldn't
call it maybe i wouldn't i'm not trying
to call a bottom here um and certainly
the macro the macro environment is you
know i'm expecting to deteriorate
further but this is just you know the
whole point of this exercise is just to
kind of highlight that in bitcoin's
history this is this is nothing new
regardless of the kind of uh dynamic
macro backdrop we see got it and so when
we go and we take a look at the drawdown
from the all-time high uh we can go all
the way back to you know maybe it's like
late 2011 early 2012. uh there's a 93
drawdown we've got in 2015 84 85
drawdown uh 2019 kind of end of 2018
there was that 84 drawdown and then
since then it looked like there had been
less severe drawdowns right so we were
kind of like let's call it 85 to 95 in
previous uh bear markets we got a 75
drawdown uh for covid we got a 50
drawdown last summer after the china
band of miners uh but the current one
has been 70 percent how do you
contextualize uh kind of what looked
like maybe less volatility to the
downside in some of these uh market
downturns uh with the longer term trend
of you know 85 95 drawdowns in bitcoin's
price
yeah it's pretty fascinating because
kind of you know after 2020 we saw you
know the the money printer go bird
narrative bitcoin breaks 20 000
absolutely flies uh and a lot of market
participants myself included were
debating whether hey is this time
different is bitcoin at a you know just
surpassed a trillion dollar uh you know
market cap at 50 000 or so uh is this
time different are we gonna see less
volatility to the downside instead of 80
drawdowns are we going to see 30 50
uh like what does what does bitcoin hold
as it continues to kind of mature as
this global macro asset uh and and funny
enough that just that thinking and that
kind of uh reinforcement to the upside
let led a lot a lot of market
participants from minors to funds
uh to to really even like the retail
participants to these lending platforms
to kind of lever up in a way that
actually presented some asymmetric
downside risk and so you know this kind
of seemingly like black swan event where
bitcoin goes straight down for the last
six months with really no bounces just
kind of consolidation periods in between
i think it was almost reinforced or
a little bit caused by a lot of these
market participants uh who have even
even like experienced bitcoiners uh who
have been you have seen cycle after
cycle thinking that hey maybe this time
is different maybe bitcoin is is mature
it's not going to draw down 70 80
percent so they lever up and all of a
sudden you know price responds to the
downside in it and it causes this kind
of force liquidation and force selling
that's that's somewhat relentless um so
it's going to be really interesting to
see just you know how far it takes or
how how low bitcoin goes before it
bottoms uh is is you know 75 80 85 90
possible 100 i mean bitcoin can always
go down 50 from its current level and i
think uh not just having that that
probabilistic thinking uh will will do
you a big disservice because it you know
you never want to become a for seller
like that's the number one rule here so
uh you know i would say now is not the
time to add to leverage don't try to
catch knives it'll be in my opinion
it'll be clear uh when the time is to
you know go out a little bit out on the
risk curve uh in bitcoin terms if you
want to do that but for the meantime
you're seeing miners with a lot of
pressure you're seeing a lot of fun
redemptions and really any bounce is
just kind of shorts closing and you know
and some scalp longs no one really wants
to take any risk here especially kind of
the tragedy world so
i think just you know i don't know
exactly how far we go from the all-time
high whether it's 80 85 etc but
uh it's just interesting that a lot of
market participants thought this time
was different and uh bitcoin humbled
everybody it seems
bitcoin humbles everyone over and over
and over again which is i think what
makes people so intellectually
interested in as well